Hello Android Developer Program engine in Android Develles
Today, we will introduce the action bar compact library.
We will.
As you know, the action bar is the most important element in Android ears
But it is only available in later versions of Honeycomb
As a result, many developers use Action Library external libraries
There is
ActionMAX Compact uses Action Foot 3 in Android 2.1 and later versions
It is the official library of the Android team that supports the
Is designed to be as close as possible to the most up-to-date api
If you use this, you can easily wear the horse in the previous version of Honeycomb
There is
First of all, how do you add ActionMac Compact to your project?
I'll see.
If you are using the latest version of Android Studio,
If you check the action bar of support mode when you create it,
You can use rival
If you are adding an action machine in an existing project,
If you are using a sdk manager,
Once you've installed it, you can add the following line to the build file:
Or you can add it directly to your library project
If you install Soft Live via the stk manager,
The compact library project is installed
You can add this library project to your shell project
Let's take a look at an actual example of using the action bar compact
This very common one has a sdk value of 14 and already uses action words
You can also use the Action's computer library
Imagine you want to modify it to work
The bosses would like it very much. To apply the action bar com bat,
I need to do some chores for that.
First, how to change the news file expressed in xml format
Let's take a look.
First you need to change the activity theme
If you want to use Action Only Compact,
You must use one of the following three themes
The AppCompact theme is a dark theme with background color and action bar mode.
Light Theme is a background color action bar mode is a bright theme fit light dark
The action horse theme surprisingly has the background color, but only the action is the dark theme
Theme can be applied to modify 2 def test
Existing hall will find the designated part of the theme,
You can modify it as applied.
One thing to use when designing an app compact theme is not to use the Android namespace
not
The App Compact theme is not included with the Android platform,
The theme that is included in the support library project to be added directly.
This is because you are defined in the plate squirrel you are working on
So let's look at some more complicated cases to make a cool app with a default theme
There are many cases where you have used an extended custom theme.
Theme is a custom theme that changes the color of the action bar slightly.
Let's modify it to Action compact type theme.
Action Bar To create a compact theme, remember that in fact,
It's possible
First, use one of the three themes described above as the parent theme
Second, all property values ​​depend on the Android version, and the Android namespace
Repeat two times with and without
So let's modify the theme file in principle.
The first principle is that instead of the Hollywood Night theme used in the existing theme
Modify to use the Compact Light theme
The second principle is to use version 10 of Sculpire,
Create a style file
If you are already on the Android platform with action level 14 or higher
All attribute values ​​are defined
So for version 14 2 4, use the Android namespace
You can specify the attribute values ​​associated with the action
However, if you are at api level 24 or earlier,
Property does not exist
To convey this, the ActionBar compact includes the attributes supported by the latest platform
An attribute with the same name is defined
These properties are the name of the project,
You can use totem space without specifying space
can
Next, you can see how the menu item can be defined as a mother compact
Let's take a look.
In general, an action button is an action button.
You can add
In ActionMac Compact, you can also use the menu item
o Plum action can be added
One thing to note, however, is that the action
The unique properties used only in the action bar are available in previous versions of Honeycomb
Because there is no
You need to use the attributes defined in your machine.
Similarly, instead of the Android namespace, the default namespace or your m
You need to leverage the namespace.
Next, let's take a look at the variations in the actual code
First of all, by default, how application activities should be changed
Let's take a look at it.
First, instead of the active activity class,
Must be inherited and implemented
This class includes the Cat class provided in the latest activity class for high compatibility
Action barstart The same action mode as the action bar action bar the
It is given the same name as the often mode
In order to actually add an action button only to an action,
In the callout function in the crate options menu,
You can plate
There is no big difference when you use an action bar computer
However, as in this example,
Action View 2 Suddenly, like the action provider, the ice cream sandwich
Because it is added to the reason, it can not be used in the previous version
To support this, the fashion magazine compact library has a menu item compact
A helper class is provided, and the class is a static method of
Methods like can action provider are defined
If you are using an action bar computer, please use this method
If you display the action bar fix foot or use the church window feature
I need a little fix
First of all, in the request bin duffy point provided by the default activity,
You must use the Forty Quest in the feature method in your activity
In order to display the progress bar,
Vindindine vitamin app house instead of team 3 support progras
The bind terminator can be used with the get get method
In addition, ActionMaine has a variety of support
Series methods are provided, so take a look at the documentation before development.
It seems good
Next, when you use fragments,
You can use fragments in place
If you want to pursue an action bar action button etc. through the frame
On the concrete pipe line, call the 3-legged option menu and press the on
Override crates option 2 or on-pre-pair options
You can add any menu item you want.
There are no major differences from existing activities.
In addition, the action bar supports various functions.
See how the Actions bar compact can take advantage of these features
Let's take a look.
First, the action bar activity is one of the new Android design patterns
Support for navigation
Just like in the case of using the key m in days,
Use the number of turns to toggle the x field included in the packaging support library
After you create the class, you come in to listen to the generated auto-layout
So you can register.
The navigation of the relief is largely divided into the encyclopedia which goes into the previous screen
You can buy it back
Platform navigation related to platform api from 4.1 onwards
Although it is supported, the action bar is convenient even in the previous version if you use the compact rival
MOM can implement navigation
First, in order to use moth navigation on the activity,
If you invoke the connectable method on your home and you are on a platform higher than version 16
Newly added to the Manifest's Kim Tae-hee,
Please specify
This child platform has the same name metadata
You can add
Next, the share action provider can easily
A widget to help you share
Click the Share button, a pop-up appears, and the user
can
You can easily find it in various Android apps including gallery elle
The chair action provider is also available with ActionMac Compact and Rogue versions
There is
Surfer tribal library spreads Hair action prominer to be included in SEVEN
You can use the class
When defining menu item properties on exem,
Instead of the namespace, you can use the default namespace defined by your app
It is usually part of the following related code:
You can use the action provider methods to add additional functionality to the auction provider.
I will implement it.
Since two major action providers are available methods after honeycomb
If you are using an action bar computer,
Using the action method of the action action action provider of the compact f class
You must
Split action As with many portrait modes,
If an action does not have enough space to display the damage action button,
Create action words and show remaining actions
To use the Spring Action Bar feature, you need to do two things
First of all, for API devices after version 14,
Add optional attribute values
This attribute is meaningful only in later versions of the ice cream sandwich,
Ignored in version
Next, to support previous versions of Android,
It adds support for Metadata to Activity 4 by option.
Search b is a widget implemented so that users can input a search word.
Seven Surfer Tribe is implemented
Super compact is also implemented version Seven library, so you can easily apply
can
However, in case of punishment in search b class, api level 8 or higher
Please note that you can use
Finally, let's look at some useful tools that can be used with ActionMac computers.
I'll do it
Action bar style Zen Light is an action foot customizer
You can change the color of each item to your desired color
You can download the results at once
At this time, when claiming assoc compact in the style com family t item, only action
A compact style file is created.
Action Marf Story Flash is a program that pushes down the list to update its contents.
This is an open source project that implements the Android design pattern.
I can check it in the latest Google apps, including updated luggage and labs.
Sharp let live also supports action compact, so your
You can easily apply the Bay pattern
So far, I've just introduced the action bar compact.
You do not need bugs or extra features when you use them.
Please leave a bug report on the calcareous site
And inside the inner make-up action bar, including the Android design guide
Thank you for your reference.